ah
[Music]
I love this movie you guys I saw it
again last night by the way I went to
they had a thing at Twitter Wow and it
was just like it was so magical and I
think it's because I watched the
original I went to the premiere watch
the original again and then went to them
really Wow yeah because I should be
interview you now the scenes are so
amazing and I think it's that side by
side so like what's your favorite scene
from the original that's what I want to
really ask you guys I like to me the
circle of life is the the whole it takes
the whole movie to get the same feeling
that you get just from that one that one
number and the colors and the
cinematography and the music and all
working together and when you try to do
something that that could could stand
side by side with that you realize how
complex it is and we went so we tried to
figure out every species every location
the lighting setups and that part we
really try to emulate as much as we
could but that to me as a piece of it's
like the beginning of up there's a few
things in movies where just it stands
alone as just a wonderful thing and that
whole opening is just to me the movies a
great film just from there I can't wait
to be king was like really influential
to me as a kid I think like I used to
watch the like behind the scenes and
you'd see them singing it and you'd and
the the colors and the dancing I just
really loved as a kid like I just felt
like it felt like this was weird but it
felt like a t-shirt or something where
it's like what the cut it felt so like
vibrant and cool that I I don't know I
just really loved it as a child yeah the
flowers is probably one of my first
memories of like them jumping in them
bursting like yeah just loved it
the other thing too Jon I know you
mentioned that we need a jungle book you
had what six or ten iconic shots that
you had to make sure we created and
this one how many I mean there were
dozens of moments it's not just shots
it's images it's lines of dialogue it's
moments it's you know scar hanging
excuse me like Mufasa hanging from his
claws the scar over him that's not an
easy thing to get a lion to do you know
to look like naturally in the naturalism
of this or them sitting side-by-side in
silhouette in a way that Lions don't
usually sit unless they're in front of a
library you know it was all go Rafiki
holding the baby up yeah there's a lot
of things that look good in 2d animation
but when you try to make it look real
you have to use tricks to get around it
well the tricks were great and
especially like I said yesterday with
your character I felt this Simba's
richer I really loved that he struggled
and he had different things to it so
going back to the original though was
there something that you wanted to make
sure you held on from the original that
you wanted to keep in your Simba and
what was something you wanted to bring
to this one I like it's funny like he I
felt in the in the original like when
you see him later and he's older with
Timon and Pumba like even with the hair
they kind of made him like I'm kind of a
slacker like kind of thing like he's
like guys it's whatever kind of like
surfer vibe which is really cool to me
but and Jon did a really good job of
like the transition of the character
throughout which I really love like it
just from the second I come on like my
voice is a little higher and it's kind
of talking like that and then slowly and
then by the time I meet my father
through me it's like oh I found I found
me like kind of and I'm I love that part
of it like that was the one thing last
night I was like oh like John did a
really good job voice changed he's had
at least three years have been you know
yeah you know life experience a
professional experience touring just
things yes your voice and and he's also
you know a different you know a
different person my dad mad now I lost
my dad while making this so like I came
back and we did some of the lines after
that happened because I was like oh I I
get it more you know so like I felt it
was very very personal thing so it felt
really good
to be able to do that I've liked my have
my favorite scenes again like there's
new ones in the new one that I love is a
favorite scene so what's your favorite
scene from the original or or from the
new one the circle of life like it's
such a crazy way to start a movie like I
really was like Marvel again and I was
like from like it's so bold and and in
it's such a big creative swing which
like again you don't generally ascribe
to like two hundred billion dollar movie
so it's like yeah it's the opening of
the movie is just and the way the title
come on comes on after the song it's
like it's a real bold start to a movie
and really impressive yeah circle of
life gives me chills every time whether
it's this version the old version and
the Broadway version it's just a great
song on some level to hear a great choir
sing circle of life just as so effective
just makes you emotional right off the
bat and yeah it is when I think about it
it is kind of like this prologue yeah to
the movie kind of bookends the movie
without actually being a part of the
story which is kind of rare nowadays the
old fashioned it really is sure almost
yes and I think that was one of my
favorite parts of press conference is
watching that performance yesterday our
press conferences saw that burden head
that exactly like no wonder comedies
were competing with
exactly why did we make longshot toys
yes of course we can keep it well God
who is the brains of this operation
we're gonna name him Fred
you guys made these characters your own
and it's so difficult I think when you
have the iconic originals and I love
them I thought they were so amazing but
was there something in the original that
you wanted to bring to your character
and also was there something you
particularly wanted to bring to this one
to say okay this is us because Fred
that's you I think the thing about the
characters more than anything that I
hope to maintain was like their their
relationship and like not the specifics
of their dynamic necessarily but just
that like these two characters like
they're all each other have and they
really like love and care about each
other and are like wildly comfortable
with one another and not offended by one
another and they just kind of like get
one another and I think like that is
like a super endearing thing to watch
and and and when they're constantly kind
of bickering it it's just funny but I
think that that more than anything was
the thing that I hope to maintain was
like their sweetness you know for me I
grew up loving Nathan Lane whose voice
work in the original is truly iconic and
no one has ever forgotten it and no one
ever will and so for me I want them to
my own spin on it but I think what
really works about timon that Nathan
created is to give him this
larger-than-life personality coming out
of this little adorable body and I
thought that was worth keeping that
because it just works so well and I
think people want to see that yeah
that's great
did you get the letter Nathan I did I
got an email from Nathan I emailed him
to ask for his blessing and he emailed
me back and was lovely and hilarious as
he always is watch this you'll get it
Simba just takes time what's y'all's
favorite scene from either the original
or this reimagining do you know what
it's all one beautiful endless day to me
I don't I can't say which scenes
I don't remember particularly but
specific scenes from the original
because I've seen
the Broadway show I've seen the touring
company so every time I see it I go oh
that's so so they all seem like one
performance to me including this each
one as layers on to the last thing I've
seen I mean I think for both of them you
know I always respond to simple
returning home you know and that just
that sense of those kind of journeys and
the journey of life and just sort of
either you know just physically or
psychologically that idea of reconciling
oneself to to home in some way is part
of all of our journeys and and and and
how we do that as part of our lives and
our completeness you know and so that
always you know as an emotionally
resonant moment for me yeah and I think
with your two characters especially they
had a lot of more color and texture
added to this version that they brought
from the stage play and from just you
guys's voices but is there anything from
the original that you wanted to bring
over so your role and was there
something particular about this role
that you were like I want to make sure
to add this extra texture well for me
again one thing I was excited about is
that we are ready it wasn't that things
were kept out of the first one but but
but we all grow the societies grow and
also our needs grow some people say this
one seems darker but we live in darker
time so we've recognized you bring when
you're an audience or a viewer you are
part of the equation it depends of what
you're bringing there so there was a
reality that that I felt with this one
that that acknowledges our present
reality and the dynamic between men and
women I'd love the fact that those when
he says you know come and eat you know
be with me
and she says I will never be your queen
it's not a put-down of him but it's that
it is a recognition of a lioness
horizont d'etre is not to be the queen
somebody's cleaner attachment
so just if she says it as it's an
impossibility I will never be your queen
I mean that's not even Shay that's just
the T right now the original had so much
sort of brand this wonderful sort of
psychological depth you know and that
Jeremy brought to scar and I just kind
of wanted to do that I mean differently
but to to really honor that you know and
honor that kind of approach to it and so
really go into all of those places and
really try to understand their to
empathize if not sympathize you know
with with a character that that does
these terrible you know despicable
things but it's so rooted in Y for
themselves you know they need to do that
you know the way you brought scar
forward though for me is that you say
you know pathetic but not sympathetic
but I felt sympathetic for the scar it
was very apparent that he had said he
had wounds and I saw him as a boy as a
cub I you know I saw him you still have
to act right but I knew that he was
wounded was what he was being that way
Thank You Alfred he looked at me crazy
yesterday when I said I felt
and the circle of life
[Music]